hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to assess
newborn reflexes so let's get started
newborn reflexes are reflexes that a
newborn baby
is born with and the reason we care
about newborn reflexes is because it
tells us how
well that nervous system is developing
and
functioning these infant reflexes also
called primitive reflexes will actually
disappear over a certain time period
which is a good thing
because it tells us again that this
neurosystem is developing like it should
therefore for exams you want to know
three things first you want to know
the names of the main reflexes that
you're going to assess
in a newborn second you want to know how
to get a response
out of those reflexes and what an
appropriate response should be
and then third you want to know about
the approximate time when these reflexes
should disappear so now let's look at
these reflexes
the first reflexes we're going to look
at are the grasp reflexes and this
includes the palmer
and the plantar grass reflex so first
the palmer grasp
palmer means we're talking about the
hand so this reflex deals with something
with the hand
so you can get a response out of the
infant whenever you place a finger
or you stroke the inside of the infant's
palm and whenever you do this the hand
will close
around it this tends to disappear around
about four to six months of age
then we have the plantar grasp and
plantar deals with the
foot so you get a response from the
infant with this whenever you place a
finger
underneath the toes and whenever you do
this the toes will actually
curl like they're grasping the finger
this disappears around about nine months
to one year of
age next is the moro reflex and this is
also sometimes called the startle reflex
so this is seen when an infant hears a
sudden loud noise they will do this
reflex
or if they experience an unexpected
movement like if you go to lay them down
and you lay them down where they're
supine
and you're supporting their head and
their heads just a little bit lower
than their body and you lay them down on
a surface they will
do this reflex so what it looks like is
that the infant will throw out their
arms hence extend them
and the palms will be upward sometimes
they'll move the arms back to the body
after doing this and they may even cry
and this reflex tends to disappear
around about six months of age
then we have the rooting reflex and this
is seen when the infant's
cheek or side of mouth is stroke the
head will actually
turn towards it and the infant's mouth
will open
in an attempt to suck so this reflex is
really helpful
in helping the baby find their food
source when they want to feed
and it tends to disappear around about
four months of age
next is the sucking reflex and just like
the rooting reflex
the sucking reflex helps the baby feed
it's going to play a role with nutrition
so you will see this whenever something
touches the top
of the infant's mouth on the inside it's
specifically that hard palate of the
mouth so the roof of the mouth the
infant will actually automatically just
start sucking it's an involuntary
thing that happens so again this helps
the infant
with feeding by allowing the infant to
pull food from
its food source like the breast or a
bottle now this reflex tends to
disappear at about four months and it
will actually become a voluntary
function
then there's the babinski reflex and
this is
seen when the bottom of the foot is
stroked from the heel
upward along the outward part of the
foot so what's going to happen
with this you will see the big toe
dorsiflex
so it's going to bend backwards and the
other toes are going to
fan out or spread out and this is what
you want to see
in an infant now in an adult you do not
want to see this response i actually
have a video
where i show you what a normal and
abnormal babinski reflex is in an adult
and you can check that video out if
you're interested and this tends to
disappear this type of response around
about one year of age
the next is the crawling reflex also
sometimes called
bower crawling reflex and how you get a
response out of an infant with this
is that you place them on their stomach
and you apply pressure
with your hand to the sole of the foot
so whenever you do this the infant will
attempt to push against thy hand with
their foot
and move the arms and legs in a crawling
like motion
and this tends to disappear anywhere
between a few weeks after birth
to a couple months next is the step
reflex and just as the name of this
reflex says this deals with the infant
taking
steps so this is seen whenever you hold
the infant
upright with the legs and the feet
touching
a surface the infant will actually move
the legs like they're taking steps or
walking
and this tends to disappear anywhere
between three to four months of
age and lastly we have the tonic neck
reflex and this is sometimes referred to
as the fencing reflex
and let that name fencing reflex help
you because it'll help you understand
how this infant will look whenever this
reflex
is initiated because fencing is a type
of sport where people fight with swords
so the response is whenever an infant's
head
is turned to a particular side the leg
and arm on that side will extend
while the leg and arm on the opposite
side will flex
similar to how those people look
whenever they're
fencing and this reflex tends to
disappear
at about four months of age okay so that
wraps up this video
over newborn reflexes and be sure to
check out the other videos in this
pediatrics series